hi guys my name is Nate Bertoni and I am
directing polka-dots the cool kids
musical for the educational premiere at
Carnegie Mellon University on March 14th
of 2016 and today we have an incredible
opportunity to talk with the creators of
the show we are in a wonderful
technological Google hangout and we have
the three writers in on video chat from
New York City so I would love for you
guys to introduce yourselves hi
everybody I'm Douglas Lyons I am the
conceive er a lyricist and co-composer
and polka dots hey guys I'm Greg
borovsky and I am a co composer for
polka-dots hi everyone I'm Melvin tons
Stoll and I am the book writer of polka
awesome so now that we've all introduced
ourselves I would love to start by
asking you guys why writing this show
was important to you specifically in
today's day and age with everything
that's going on I really feel like this
show has such a crucial message at this
point in time and the audience that it's
written for is broad it's you know it's
specifically geared towards a certain
audience but it's broad and that anyone
that watches it will enjoy it and I
would love to hear from you guys why you
were interested in writing it as a team
I'll I'll start it it was inspired for
me I saw a very interesting video
interview of phylicia rashad talking
about growing up in the Jim Crow South
in the 1960s and being a little black
girl with this obsession for a white
only water fountain and when no one was
looking one day she wouldn't tasted that
water to only find out that it was the
same water that was in the Negro
fountain and her quote is that humanity
tried to trick himself to believe that
it could divide the races and that sort
of sparked something in me and then I
did a little research on the Little Rock
Nine and would be bridges and I'm a
writer personally who likes to bring
diversity to the stage and this topic
just it's both
and I called Melvin about a year ago a
little over a year ago to to ask him to
join the team as well as Greg so that's
how I got into it
Melvin made me go next yeah I mean it
was really as simple as coming to me and
saying so I have an idea and he gave me
the treatment for it and what he was
thinking it was a no-brainer I grew up
in the south and was often the you know
only black guy in the room and so that's
kind of been my journey and it has
always been super important to me you
know to try to fit in or to try to show
that you know there really is a
universal humanity out there and so it
really it was like there's no way I'm
not going to do this and my personal
riot
is geared towards families and it seemed
like a really good match and Doug and I
have been friends working unbeautiful
about a year so it was you know I had
been watching his growth as a writer and
how he really had carved out such a
beautiful name for himself in the
business so to be able to be able to be
a part of it and to get on the Douglas
line wagon it was very very easy
decision yeah and for me you know I
actually met Doug when I first came to
New York I'm also from the south I smell
smells but myself the south of Africa so
you know coming here to New York from
South Africa just a little under two
years ago the first time I got to meet
Doug was when I went to see lines and
Petra concert at Lincoln Center and I
was just blown away by his music and his
talent so I got to meet him after and we
chatted and just discussed you know why
I had come over and then a couple months
later he sent me you know just the voice
notes about a concept that he was
working on it and this show about this
you know this little girl lady polkadot
and explained the concept and just
resonated so much from
having grown up in South Africa you know
I was 12 years old in South Africa
transition from apartheid to democracy
and I was 16 years old by the time I was
first integrating with other black kids
and you know making making my first
black friends and I just you know
realized what beauty must have been lost
on both sides by the segregation that
was thrust upon us and you know nobody
wins with segregation that's what I
realized so this project really spoke to
me and would speak to I think so many
people around the world you know
especially South Africans who would have
grown up you know in the same
environment
incredible that's you know a lot of that
information is some information that I
haven't heard from all of you so far yet
so that's that's great to hear and I
think great for any audience that will
get to see this to hear as well I think
the next thing which we somewhat talked
talked about in this last conversation
is where the inspiration came from this
came from for this new musical and we
talked about the video interview that
you watched but I'd love to go a little
bit more in depth into that conversation
if you have any more tidbits of how
moments in the show are inspired as
we've been in rehearsal for the last
couple weeks you know we've been finding
really really beautiful moments in the
music and lyrics in the book of the show
there are some incredible moments of
heartfelt storytelling in there and I'd
love to to hear if you have any insight
for anyone that will be able to see the
show into what some of those moments
mean to you or where they came from
specifically for any of you I think I've
learned the most exciting experience
thus far as a writer I think has been
this project partially because it's
picked up and gelled so quickly and been
successful so quickly but as far as
inspiration goes I'll start there and
then I'll transfer it to some of the
smaller bits inspiration for the way
that it's laid out so the way the
polkadots happens it's a four person
cast and it can be done with actors of
any ethnicity in any role because the
idea is that all of the actors in the
play appear in makeup and when writing
for children you know there's so much
useful material out there and I actually
frozen the whole let it go thing that
happened and what every kid in America
was screaming the back seat of the car
my parents wanted to get in cars man on
purpose that whole movement influenced
my mind is like well what is the way to
change the minds of people who haven't
made the decisions yet we're still
learning it's the next generation if
polka-dots was an adult show that was we
were trying to bring to Broadway it
might not be as received as well but
there's something about the youth and
inside of their minds because they don't
think the way that we think they don't
see color they see friendship they say
see fun and that was part of the
inspiration for the makeup that they
could come to the theater and not see
themselves reflected on stage and
pigment but in an experience and in love
so that that was part of the inspiration
and I'll come back to moments later and
we can go to the next person
Melvin well I'm glad ray did you say
that oh yeah as in well I can definitely
speak of you know a specific moment that
kind of you know says it all for me and
that the show where the kids cover their
eyes and they just have her Congress
does a picture no too late
there was a great picture that was going
around on Facebook and it was a little a
little by kick kid hugging a little
black boy and that you know he does talk
and I was I just just loved that because
you see in these two kids like Doug was
like I was saying they don't see color
they just see they just say another
another human that did interact with and
so that moment for me where the kids
just cover their eyes and they have a
conversation and they find all of these
you know things that they that they both
like and that they both are dancing and
and for me that's the heart of the show
it's like get past what's on the outside
and and the end of the day we're all the
same on the inside we you know skin
colors may change but the core of
humanity is the same and so for me that
specific moment was very very special
that kind of happened I didn't plan and
it just was sudden it was like boom
let's just do this and see where it went
it and that that moment is very very
special for me I think or before Greg
speaks I just want to say that a that
moment in rehearsal for us between
Mahalo and Jordan who are actors playing
lily and Skye
been kind of one of the most I guess
well-received on my end but also just
easily translated from page to stage
that moment was really really stunning
to see I didn't have to direct a single
thing for with this process in general
I've really let the actors tell the
story through through their experiences
as well and kind of just guided to
believe to make it what I think we all
want to see on stage but Mahalo and
Jordan with that moment found something
really really beautiful staging it on
their own and I I can't wait for you
guys to experience that and see what
it's like to have that on stage for the
first time I think covering their eyes
and kind of revealing themselves to each
other in that dialogue that's there and
the sprinkler suspicion music that's you
know around the same time in the show is
really really beautiful right yeah I
think that's that's quite a key point
that you make there Nate it's it almost
is symbolic of the process or the the
journey that this whole show is taking
it's it almost seems to have happened
quite seamlessly like you said you know
you don't even have to sit back and
direct it it just manifested and formed
itself it feels like for us as the
writers this has happened so quickly and
I mean I don't want to say effortlessly
because you know it's been a lot of hard
work but within a period of six months
for me personally from receiving Doug's
first voice notes saying hey I've got
this idea to you know having our first
reading in New York it's just when when
something feels right and is wratten's
and spreads the right message is just
you know I thank God that it just it
just happens so seamlessly um but for
Mia in this there's a moment I'm talking
specifically in the show both both
musically and lyrically which talks to
the process that you know when we
started working on this piece and I
don't want to speak for Doug in terms of
concept but I think his initial concept
was about racially you know black and
white and skin and I think once we
started developing it we all realized
that we were onto something here and it
and it grew in it and it just
organically built itself into something
that was so much more and one of my
favorite moments in the piece and I
don't want to give away the ending or
anything but is is when towards the end
when we realized that it's you know this
message is not just about skin and race
it's about any bullying and about any
art costs that feel they're not welcome
and in the finale there's a moment where
musically we start to really pick it up
and and you know from a progression
point of view it builds up to tie in
with the new lyrics and the message that
if you're gay or straight or a bit
overweight or whatever it may be that
you're dealing with you're a cool kid so
so that's one of my special moments
there that it gets me choking up a
little bit
incredible something that you guys
brought up during this conversation that
wasn't initially a question in my head
is I'd love to speak about how fast this
process has been and I'd love to talk
about transitioning into why we're doing
this at carnegie-mellon I'd love to talk
about how fast it has been since I first
met Doug for the first time in November
and how this may potentially inspire
someone to keep doing theater and keep
writing but how fast things can happen
if you set your mind to it and for all
of you you know I saw you may have not
realized that this was going to happen
but I saw sticks and stones the demo on
Facebook and Douglas knows this I saw
the demo on Facebook after one of my
cast members Jordan had liked it on your
page and Jordan had liked the the song
and Douglass's page and I saw it as
naturally you do on Facebook and I
listened to it and was blown away by one
its message to the actress singing it
and three how how beautiful you guys had
beautifully you had crafted a story in
just one song already so I saw that and
I immediately knew that I needed to
reach out to you guys and you know maybe
three weeks after
Douglas and I had met in New York and we
we spoke about what we wanted to do and
how I could help you guys bring this
story to the world and I want to talk to
you guys and hear more but how fast this
has really been for you I know that you
said March of 2015 was it Douglas
well Martin it yeah March of 2015 was
when I committed to it so it actually
came to me the idea came to me September
of 2014 sitting on my couch I was dating
someone at the time and I brought it up
and we actually sort of got into an
argument about it because I thought it
needed to be intimate I was like we can
do this with three to four people and
and their opinion was that it should be
bigger you know you did and I was like
no I think I think it could be an
intimate and so I sort of put it on a
shelf but sometimes you do as an artist
you get discouraged and you're like oh I
don't know that seems too difficult to
figure out so I actually put it away but
it kept sort of circling back in my
heart and my mind and I was like
forgiveness I'm just I'm gonna go for it
and that's actually when I sort of wrote
the first demo down and sent it to Greg
this process is rare this does not
happen you do not go from a 29 hour
reading in August to a full production
and more it's rare it's lightning
striking but I think it's a testament of
the work ethic of these two gentlemen
and our respect from one another as
collaborators to not mean to tied to the
material that we were bringing to the
table we cut one of the songs like the
day of with you either the day of night
before the reading in August and and
then there was a magic in the room where
people just they were listening and the
adults were laughing we we call it a kid
show but the I think the adults left
moved more than some of the kids we had
in the reading that day and and and so
that this show is really a testament I
think to not dismissing an idea it's a
people that you trust and going for it
whether it be you know a big
or it gets one production of one reading
you created a thing that is now alive in
the world and if I had never really gone
for it and just left it on that shelf we
wouldn't be here I mean maybe we would
have but like not now it would have been
who knows what so that's sort of my
timeline of how this has all happened
but the process of feeding off one you
know one another's energy and brilliance
and and efforts has gotten us here
because you know there are song
suggestions that Melvyn me that we ended
up writing and then and then it just it
bloomed it bloomed so I have that pushed
absolutely so I'd love to talk briefly
about why Carnegie Mellon and when we
discussed Carnegie Mellon and discuss
the possibility of doing it in an
educational setting in an educational
premier kind of how that interest you
and I know that the audience is for our
specific production going to be a wide
range of people we have I've confirmed
today that we actually have a couple
troops of young children coming as part
of a polka dot party which will we'll
learn more about one student decided and
their parents decided to invite their
classmates and they're gonna make it
some sort of a polka dot party for them
but we also have we also have the deans
are schools and high school students
middle school students and we have
college-age students so our our range of
age is going to be pretty pretty wide
and I think why I want to do it at
Carnegie Mellon and you can speak to
this too is that I feel that this show
is most important today to be received
by an audience that is
multi-generational because I feel that
with everything going on in the world
with you know these conversations that
sometimes we just don't want to have and
sometimes we have a lot of the times we
need to be learning from the young
generations like you said who who may
not see color and major see friendship
but certainly will have opinions on what
they see on stage you know kids aren't
shy to to share their opinions of what
they've seen on stage so once we do
polka-dots will we'll hear from a lot of
children and students as well as adults
what they feel about this show and what
you know what their emotional responses
to it but I think for me that's one of
the most important things is about
bringing this show to see me as allowing
you guys to have the chance for the
first time maybe the second time
depending on what you're reading held
but to have an audience that is as
diverse of an age range as we hope and
see how everyone across the board
receives the same show yeah I think we
are you Nathan massive you know that of
gratitude for for being you know as for
thinking and his groundbreaking you know
for you know from from my point of view
coming here from the outside and just
seeing how much Doug and Mel we're
freaking out when you first let us know
they caught you many wanted to put this
on it's it's inspirational and it gives
us hope and you know and every new
writer out there that is working on
something that's new and and you know
fresh it's great to have the platform
that you that you guys are giving so
yeah from us to you thank you man
absolutely I mean now Carnegie Mellon is
is excellent so to to be able to say
that you know we premiered there's just
for me it's just huge like you know it's
Carnegie Mellon had so many of you know
Broadway's legendary performers Tony
winners you know all come from that
school so to you know to be able to have
the material presented in such an
excellent way and I might be said to
such a diverse audience really is one of
those like how is this happening to us
in in less than a year
absolutely for granted at all my kid ins
it is a complete honor so thank you and
thank you social media and Doug for
unique you know
well it's true I mean you know that
doesn't science is you know one of the
hardest-working men in this business and
just from a collaboration point of view
just to to be part of the process but
also learning so much of you know how
when you even something and even it is
so deep in your heart and it's something
that you know it's I have to do it I
feel like that's what happened music I
have to make this happen
and then the world responds and it's
like this is why because it is a message
that is needed right now
cross the board and the moment were the
show you know transmission from just
being a racial issue to all you know all
of the bullying issues that came and and
to see that response of you know the
parents people saying you know I've
heard it I've read about the story and
my kid eats this you know I know he now
looking back on high school and being in
howcast's a lot of the you know a lot of
us theater kids you know we you know we
were outcasts I mean in in high school
because it wasn't sports it was no drama
and art um I think it resonates so much
you know throughout this community and
and so so it's really it was really
special to see it go beyond and just
kind of bloom into it's not I remember
Doug saying it's you know it used to
just be black and white but now it's you
know it's gay straight it's fat
overweight and you know and all those
lyrics that you know eventually work
there where we realized that it was so
much bigger than that I think what we
even imagined so I would I want to let
you know if I see those kids and the
polka dot party outfit I'm gonna lose it
I almost lost it on that yeah he's gonna
be a Rick just just please make sure
there are a lot of over there well I
think what's also interesting about the
educational setting is you know that
we've been picked up by some social
media and Broadway world in a couple
places
to let people know that we're out there
and this show is happening and I've you
know we've started a gmail account polka
dots musical CMU at gmail.com if you
want to email it to get tickets so we've
we've started that and every day I've
been getting more and more emails saying
hey I'd love to reserve two tickets I'd
love to reserve two tickets and today I
actually received one about a book I
didn't know about and I'm not sure if
you any of you have read it but I
believe the title was the lions at
Little Rock and it was a book that these
two young girls have read for school in
Pittsburgh and it sparked my interest I
hadn't heard of the book and now I will
go pick it up but a mother had emailed
me saying that her daughters had read
this book at school and they want to
come see she wants them to come see this
new show to continue the conversation
and to spark that conversation so one of
the biggest things also for me is that
the element of hopefully now that we've
done this or are viewing this on Monday
now that we have this connection and you
know I love this show I don't think I
could ever step away from this show
unless you guys write something you know
next that we have to step away for a
brief second brief second but this show
I'd love to see go into every school I'd
love to see you know have a sit-down in
Pittsburgh where schools can come see it
on Tuesday mornings at 10:00 a.m. or you
know it can come and be there their
lunch room entertainment in a way where
it can be a formal show it can be a
formal sit-down
you know off-broadway type show where
kids go every morning at 10 a.m. but it
can also be something that's as simple
as these students putting on a polkadot
dress and you know a plaid shirt and
performing it in their schools and I
think what the hope where I come from
what the hope with starting at a
Carnegie Mellon is is that we all know
without ego that Carnegie Mellon has the
name in the drama industry you can look
at the people that have graduated you
can look at these alumni
and you know Carnegie Mellon is paving
the way for recognition of education in
theater with the Tony Award for
Excellence in educational I just
butchered that I apologize the Tony
Award for Excellence in education
theater education they have started
something that is should converse it's a
conversation that's needed we have all
of these elementary and middle school
and high school drama teachers that were
our teachers and we're the people that
inspired us to you know keep doing this
and now they're being recognized so I
think Carnegie Mellon is paving the way
in that respect and what I want to see
it continue to do is pave the way with
shows like this and with polka dots and
if there's any way in the future
although I am a senior and graduating if
there's any way that I can work with
Carnegie Mellon to continue some sort of
production of polka dots for the
students of Pittsburgh and any state
across the country or the world to see
in some way it neat I think it needs to
happen and it is that conversation
that's not just rates its whether you've
been bullied or not which most people at
that age have most people today at our
age you know they're still being bullied
in the workplace on the street whatever
I think everyone can benefit from this
show and I may be a little long-winded
in my response right now but to sum that
all up my I want to thank you guys for
giving me this opportunity I remember
talking to Douglas and you know maybe
you all didn't have the same whether I
was the right person to do this but I
have been you know loving every moment
that I've been working on this show and
we've you know we've talked about it and
I've talked about it with the cast I've
talked about it with my friends and yes
I you know I am a white male who as we
talked about in the industry white white
males are pretty much everywhere but the
opportunity to work on the
show that talks to about aspects of
bullying that I've experienced in my
life and just not even what I've learned
from this is not even that I need to
direct like you guys talked about I
don't this show doesn't necessarily need
a director it just needs four actors
that have experienced some sort of this
conversation in their life and the
second they get the script the second
they hear the music for the first time
you should I mean you have but you will
be blown away the next time you get to
see an actor's face for the first time
that they hear this music I know the
first time that one of our producers
sure Nell Smith or the music she
immediately immediately responded to the
show and I think it's that I think in
that conversation as much as every
theater piece needs a director this show
is more about for actors and a creative
team coming together and all having
experienced some form of being an
outcast in their life so thank you for
allowing me to help you guys tell this
story yeah thank you I mean thank you I
think one thing that Melbourne said one
time during the reading was that you
know this show was not only for those
that are being bullied but it's for the
bullies to see themselves on the stage
to see what they're doing to other
people you know there's this whole have
a lot of transgendered friends and I
mean there there are maybe there's every
two to three weeks there's a murder of a
transgendered person across America
especially for transgendered people of
color and or or suicide and it's an
exact it's sad you know it's sad that
they feel like they have nowhere to go
it's sad that people can't allow people
to exist without persecuting them you
know like even if you don't understand
someone to teach children it's okay to
ask questions instead of poking fun at
that mole or at that roll
what is that I don't have that but what
is that you know it's how we train our
children my mother says you know train
the children up as they should go and
they will never depart it's it's it's
how we how we build them up to be great
human beings so by the time they are
adults we're not being horrible to each
other that we're not trying to push
people over borders that we're saying I
don't understand you but I want to
figure out how I can you know so again
the polka dot party I'm just I'd the kid
to do this anymore
like I just see those little girls and
new dresses walk in and feel and feel
and it's the other thing it's feeling
empowered the reason it's not just polka
dots the musical but polka dots the cool
kids musical is because hopefully by the
time of these kids leave the theater
they all feel cool that every single one
of them fat tall skinny blind
handicapped they all feel cool and if
we've done that all right another show I
don't have to write anything else in my
life if we achieve a way to make these
kids feel empowered we want yeah yeah I
just want to maybe build on what Nate
was saying you know in terms of getting
a message to these kids at at this age
at a young age you know we don't realize
the messages that are coming from the
media whether they're subliminal or
explicit that are actually spreading the
message that difference means inequality
and for me that's that's kind of what
polka dots you know is achieving or
hopefully will achieve is that it
spreads the message that difference
doesn't mean inequality you know no
matter how different we may seem or
appear to be or whatever different
cultures or whatever it doesn't it
doesn't mean the same thing as
inequality everyone is worthy and
everyone is equal and and that's the
sooner we can get that message to
counter the message that is being fed to
the kids now the better and we can get
it to all the kids across America and
across the whole world to be honest with
you that the better it's a case of
emergency
yeah yeah we've had such a great
conversation questions that I had are
kind of all they've all been answered
but what I'm what I'm curious about is I
guess one thing that you look forward to
specifically besides the polka dot party
and the little girls in their pocket
addresses one thing that you you know
having worked on this show for this long
so far one thing that you're excited
about seeing come to life on Monday
for the first time you know whether
whether we're learning from this or you
know and it's something that may not
reflect exactly what you had in your
mind and we learn from that or something
that you maybe hadn't thought of that is
suddenly oh wow look at that moment
there it is in the show and something
you know as a show grows obviously
through the process of whether it's
previews or workshops something that
you're excited about learning or seeing
you may not have an answer
it may be an after-the-fact question no
I mean i definitely for me it's as scary
as it can be to not be a part of the
process i mean we obviously trust you
all to just go and and see how you know
house you know what you guys have done
with it and i think for me that's what's
most exciting just to see how the the
truth of the story plays out without us
being there going well it needs to be
this it needs to be this but just to
take on it and those apps how those
words have affected them and how they
how they present them i mean that was a
really cool thing about the audition
process when when we were here in the
city just seeing how people read the
words and how they heard them and and so
for me as you know i I know I can be a
little hands-on and want to be there and
make sure that is how I how I thought it
will be very very exciting just to see
how the truth of the story is
find out without us you know being there
and that's you know that's it's that's
exciting I think I'm even just to hear
about you know Colin Jordan how they
have just you know found their moments
and how they played that saying I was
like man I can't wait to see to see them
and to see how they how they played this
scene out so yeah I mean I think just to
get there and just sit back and go okay
you know show us our show yeah well to
piggyback off of that real quick we had
a we had a rehearsal one day without a
rehearsal space we know that you know
current email and all the rehearsal
spaces are booked for certain hours so
sometimes we're rehearsing 9:00 to
midnight but one day we decided to
rehearse over dinner and Jordan and
Mahalo were reading all of the scenes
between Lily and Skye and you guys can
feel comfortable that you have written
something that translates well into the
readers mind because we were sitting
around the table and they would be going
back and forth having this conversation
around their dinner tables their dinner
table and people from outside people
from other tables would look over and be
like what is this a monologue
what is this is a conversation or are
you are you actually having this
conversation or is this something that
is written through the stage so some of
these scenes are so just natural to what
we'd be we'd be want you know we would
want to hear between Lily and Skye and I
think that was one in a moment that will
stay with me forever rehearsing over a
plate of dining hall food story and I'm
excited was I mean obviously so much you
know as Mel said mister yeah I guess the
translation or at least you know your
guys depiction of this piece that we've
created but I don't know if the other
guys have realized this will be the
first time musically that we're gonna
hear a full band actually rock out the
score so I picked me I'm so excited to
just yeah how full bands
you know takes takes the notes if we put
on a page and brings that to life better
yeah you might have to get a few Kleenex
for me but yeah I can't wait to rock out
great I'm excited because we in pitching
the show which tya theater for young
audiences is one of the hardest
departments in the theater I mean
theater in general it's hard to get your
work produced because everything costs
money and nobody has it or wants to use
it and that's fine but the tya pitch is
hard for this show because people see
kids musical and they think like I don't
know where I'm gonna place that of my
season and what I'm excited about is
sitting in a 400-seat theatre with kids
and parents and taking notes on how they
react and when they react and what what
sort of makes them smile what makes them
dance you know that's gonna be
educational for us because we are to
development to a premier and Connecticut
the Ironton Playhouse in April and so if
there any changes that are gonna happen
between CMU and iving 10 we'll learn
them on on Monday night so you know as a
rider you learn it's not about your
intentions of what you think it should
be it's how the audience receives it and
that is what you should listen to so I'm
excited to hear that to like sit next to
them cry but also like listen to when
the kids are laughing or when they're
sleeping or when they're looking around
in the air because that means you've
lost their you know attention so that's
gonna be great for us wonderful yeah I
just thinking about that conversation
and thinking about the normal process of
writing a show and being involved in you
know the first read the first workshop
and the first production I feel like
this is just this entire process of us
doing this show at Carnegie Mellon is
such a unexpected order of events for
something to happen this is you know
before you guys go and do this at I've
read to Playhouse you you have the
opportunity to send it off to a group of
actors
have them you know read it for the first
time in a very different setting where
you guys are coming to just show up and
see it which i think is exciting and
obviously terrifying and great it's
gonna be an experience for all of us I
think specifically myself and the actors
were learning a great deal from doing
from doing this you know brand new show
that's never been touched in a way um
yeah so to wrap up I guess I would love
to just say thank you for everything
that you guys are doing to get this show
possible on our end and I can't wait for
us to bring this show to Pittsburgh in
six days that soon already Oh everyone's
facial expression yeah six days so it
seems like we've been working I've been
working on it for months but you've been
working on it for at least a year if not
more so it will be amazing to have you
sit in the audience and watch what we've
created together and what's happening
and if you have any final thoughts I'd
love for you to share them if not I have
I have passed you my questions
I'll just say thank you thank you to
Carnegie Mellon University to you ensure
now for putting this together to the
actors for their time I know in college
you want to sleep and like party and not
do new musical necessarily at the end of
the semester so appreciate that and yeah
we're excited to fly there and be in the
room and hopefully those little polka
dot children in the polka dot party
though their hearts will be warm yeah I
guess I'll just jump in and say thanks
so much and uh I really hope you guys
have as much fun putting it on stage and
the audience says as much fun watching
it as we've had you know writing it yeah
ditto to all the things all right thank
you guys so much
and I look forward to seeing you all on
Monday March 14th at 7 p.m. why